Michael's physics book a comprehensive
introduction to differential geometry
really means topology I suspect but says
Oh a classical theorem of topology
States a little bit a little - which of
these standard surfaces are the
following homeomorphic a hole in a hole
in a hole if I solve this what is it
well if I head over the glass shop and I
said I can make that so I made a hole in
a hole in a hole there's a hole that
goes through a hole that's in a hole
in the book it's in paper here it's
glass how do I simplify this to
something that answers physics question
so let me take that inner hole and
stretch it a little bit now one of these
holes is untouched
but what used to be a ring around this
is now stretched out it's almost an
ellipse well that's okay
in topology because I can stretch things
haven't changed much let's go a little
bit further I'm going keep pulling that
this way until this piece of glass that
I'm just touching right now the end of
my finger is coming all the way up I'm
going to stretch this oh about two or
three centimeters further this way until
it starts to pop out the other end so
now what had been a ring has stretched
out and I'm now touching that place
let's keep going now this part of the
hole and this part of the hole I'm gonna
move these I'm gonna push the glass
until it's almost wishbone shaped this
will pull this way I'll pull this one
over here this is the original beast
however instead of this coming around
like this that piece of glass now is
continuous across
we've broken know topological rules in
fact we've just assumed that this is
strictly flexible glass end at 1200
degrees Fahrenheit it is flexible glass
now that we have this oh I'm gonna pull
this up around here and this over to
there we're gonna straighten it out so
the wishbone here has become a t-bone
tip oh and this is straight through it's
still the same beast that we started
with but we've just moved the holes
around we move things around is it still
a hole in a hole in a hole well it's
still the original thing that's been
topologically reshaped the rules are we
can't cross things we can't tear
anything but we can move these around
and that's what we've been doing let's
instead of going straight across let's
go boink boink let's make this into
something that's a little bit more curvy
from here over to here notice we still
have this hole is the same as this hole
is that okay if I'm pointing with my
nose so these are still topologically
the same the intersection of the tee is
now the intersection of two curves and
you can see what we're going to do next
the next step I'm going to do is to pull
this tube over here and pull this tube
over here remember here's one of those
holes now we've separated those holes so
that it's now three tubes one tube here
this tube this tube let's go back to
what was the source of that and you can
see we've simply pulled those tubes long
nothing was torn haven't added heads
haven't subtracted from it has it been
torn all I'm doing is pulling this hole
along to here in this hole further along
here so I'm just pulling that outward
and in so doing
forcing this tube to the side this tube
to the side I now have a tube a tube and
who given this let's straighten this
tube so I've got this this tube I'm
gonna bring this whole ship around here
this hole around here pull them really
straight like this so now those two
curved tubes are two straight tubes and
I have another straight tube here okay
now it's a piece of cake all I have to
do is pull these two to be parallel to
this one or alternatively rotate this
tube to be parallel with these two so
let's try here's all three of those
tubes parallel so all three holes are
now parallel and now this is getting
close to a solution
I'll take this in one hand this in
another I'm gonna squash it I'm gonna
push it down this way so instead of a
sphere I'm going to compress it down
until it's more like a pancake I'll get
something that's pancake shaped but the
three holes are still there there's also
a tiny little hole there when you make
hand-blown glass it's necessary to have
a little hole to let out hot air ignore
that guy these are the main three and Oh
doesn't take much to say this is a three
hole torus this is a torus with one two
three holes in it which is a nice way of
answering Spivak square
how would I manipulate this into a
solution a three hole torus will make
any topologist in the universe happy but
let's go back and try something else
let's go back one step
never had this guy and I said we're
gonna squash this down to here instead
let's pull this tube over towards the
side so right now it's near the middle
let's pull it over towards the side in
fact let's pull it almost to the edge
and we'd find that it would be possible
to go through it if we kept pulling it
we could pop it out from here we can
make a sphere with three handles I'm
jumping over several steps but think of
this right here is a handle
I could put a chain right through here
pick it up right put a string through
here pull this outward this is the same
as this notice that hole there is the
same as this hole a second hole and a
third hole here's a three handled sphere
a sphere with one two three handles this
three handled sphere is homeomorphic to
this three hold sphere and that's
homeomorphic to this three whole torus
if I have this three handled sphere I
can go to my glass shop heat it up put
my hand right there push down right here
and push down really hard and from here
I can transform this into a three
handled coffee mug this is a three
handled bug a three handled drinking
glass that's homeomorphic to and has the
same properties as this 3 hold torus a 3
hold donut and that is the solution to
the question what does this map unto
thanks to audible.com for supporting
this video if you haven't discovered
audiobooks here as a great way to catch
up on excellent writing well you've been
missing out after numerous
recommendations from friends I've
finally been listening to ready player
one I actually became a bit obsessed
with it on a recent holiday every spare
a few minutes I had I was listening to a
bit more of the book I don't want to
give anything away about it because I
really enjoyed going into a cold knowing
nothing I want you to have the same if
that's possible but I do recommend it
highly
but whatever kind of riding you're into
you can rest assured audibles gonna have
something you'll like and when you do
sign up you get your first month and
your first book for free do that at
audible.com slash numberphile said I
know you came from this channel and if
you do download a book that say you
don't like audible let you exchange it
for another I've actually done in
exchange myself and it was really easy
but I don't think you'll want to
exchange ready player one it's a really
good recommendation for your first audio
book really well read by Wil Wheaton
give that book a try give audible a try
and thanks to them for supporting
numberphile yet again
the changes that have happened from one
to the next to the next have not
required moving things through one
another